avec nous le ministre des finances eric
girard à québec monsieur girard bonsoir
bonsoir on a l'impression en regardant
les premières neiges ces jours ci que
c'est noël
un mois et demi avant le temps est ce
que c'est l'esprit féerique du temps des
fêtes qui vous anime pour faire des
cadeaux comme ça aux familles à votre
mise à jour mais c'est à dire que les
les finances publiques appartiennent aux
québécois l'économie du québec performe
remarquablement bien et ça stimule les
rentrées fiscales et donc nous avons
décidé de remettre de l'argent au
contribuable tout en maintenant une
saine gestion des finances publiques
pourriez pas prendre cet argent là pour
les ré investir davantage dans les
missions de l'état santé éducation
mais comme en avait besoin le dernier
budget a donnée à l'éducation et à la
santé un niveau de dépense supérieure à
5% alors le budget était
le budget du métier
à domicile au niveau de la santé était
le budget du réinvestissement dans
l'école publique
est ce cette mise à jour c'est pour les
contribuables et donc vous considérez
que c'est que c'est réglé que le
réinvestissement dans l'émission c'est
correct comme ça c'est à dire que le
il faut donner le temps aux mesures
d'avoir leurs effets il y aura trois
autres budgets de notre gouvernement et
non de tout n'est pas réglé en santé en
éducation
mais c'est pas juste une question
d'argent c'est aussi une question
de productivité d'allocation des
ressources
il ya des efforts importants à faire en
santé en éducation et nous avons donné
les moyens financiers pour sûr je
comprends mais quand on parle de déficit
éventuellement structurel ou en tout cas
de situations où on verrait l'économie
croître à un rythme beaucoup plus normal
que ce qu'on a présentement avec des
coûts d'intérêt qui sont plus élevés que
ce qu'on a présentement parce qu'on a
actuellement de façon surprenante des
intérêts qui sont moins élevés on
imagine qu'on va être beaucoup moins
serrés que la marge de manoeuvre va
partir et là il sera plus temps de
réinvestir de réengager de l'argent dans
les missions essentielles de l'état mais
nous avons déjà prévu dans le cadre
financier nous prévoyons déjà quatre
points six pour cent par année en santé
de l'accroissement du budget comprend
mais c'est davantage que 4,6 pour cent
mais commençons par des pensées le 4
points c'est le 4.4 le vieil or il ya de
l'argent qui est sur la table déjà un
effort considérable et les contribuables
vous savez nous voulons augmenter le
potentiel l'économie du québec
nous voulons remettre de l'argent au
contribuable et améliorer les services
on peut faire tout ça en même temps en
faisant les bons choix en ayant une
gestion responsable
moi je suis convaincu que beaucoup de
familles avec des enfants
beaucoup de familles qui sont très
heureuses de voir de l'argent revenir
donc là la taxe famille partir par
exemple on le dit assez souvent que de
tarifs et deux fois le même service pour
des gens en fonction de leurs revenus
était quelque chose d'un peu étrange sur
le plan fiscal ça vous l'enlever en même
temps le québec est vu comme un paradis
des familles depuis depuis longtemps sur
le plan fiscal
est-ce qu'on a encore besoin encore
besoin de réduire les charges fiscales
des familles mais en fait les québécois
sont extrêmement taxer et oui nous avons
besoin de réduire le fardeau fiscal
ben c'est pas tout simplement les impôts
les taux d'imposition se dit qu'on est
extrêmement oui nous avons commencé lors
du dernier budget avec la baisse des
taxes scolaires lorsqu'on combine les
taxes municipales et les taxes scolaires
nous sommes les numéros un au canada
au niveau de la charge fiscale alors
nous avons amorcé la réduction de la
taxe cola nous avions deux promesses
phares bonifier les allocations famille
à 2500 $ pour chacun des enfants s'est
accompli un an après notre élection une
autre province force et le taux unique
de taxation scolaire pour l'ensemble du
territoire
33 % de cette promesse l'aï fait nous
avons l'intention de la réaliser on
verra au prochain budget quelles sont
nos marges de manoeuvre
ensuite viendront possiblement s'il y a
toujours des marges de manoeuvre
dépendamment de l'évolution d'économie
il pourrait y avoir des réductions du
fardeau fiscal
est-ce que vos projections sont trop
conservatrices parce que depuis quelques
temps et toujours des revenus
supplémentaires et des dépenses de -
finalement ce qu'on a observé puis moi
ça fait un an que je suis
ministre des finances ce qu'on a observé
au cours des cinq dernières années c'est
que les revenus étaient supérieurs on a
accumulé 12 milliards de surplus dans
les quatre dernières années la moitié de
ça est associé aux revenus l'autre
moitié c'est des dépenses inférieures à
ce qui avait été prévu
alors c'est 50 50 alors c'est certain
que si un ralentissement économique
l'aspect revenu va se régulariser
au niveau des dépenses on a un défi l'an
dernier nous avions prévu une croissance
des dépenses que c'est l'ancien
gouvernement et le nouveau gouvernement
puisque c'était unanimes les deux
gouvernements se chevauchaient nous
avions prévu 5% de croissance de
dépenses nous avons réalisé seulement 3
pour ça c'est ça donc
autrement dit on fait des projections
puisse pas autre chose dans la réalité
mais ça c'est tout on évolue d'un vous
savez l'économie il ya de l'incertitude
qui sont de plus en plus grand mais on a
un budget qui est 117 milliards de
revenus un homme moi j'ai révisé 2018
2019 par rapport à mon budget de 2
milliards 2 millions 67 millions c'est
moins d'un pour cent ans et résonnèrent
bon j'ai une dernière question monsieur
le ministre comme ministre des finances
est ce que vous vous inquiétez de la
perception que les gens peuvent avoir en
ce moment propos du débat je pars du
débat sur des étudiants étrangers les
seuils d'immigration c'est quand même
directement liées à l'économie
est-ce que vous avez est ce que vous
croyez ce que vous pensez ce que vous
craignez que des étudiants des
immigrants des investisseurs des
immigrants investisseurs des entreprises
peuvent avoir une mauvaise perception du
québec
en fait moi ce que j'aimerais dire
aujourd'hui c'est que la contribution de
l'immigration c'est important de le dire
à l'économie du québec et l'économie
canadienne est extrêmement positive et
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que nous avons
augmenté le poste budgétaire que le plus
augmenté dans mon premier budget c'était
l'immigration le deuxième c'était
l'environnement ne jouent pas leur
perception qu'on voulait avoir de
l'extérieur
pays où j'ai des gens qui se disent on
va aller au québec mais est-ce qu'on
veut encore aller au québec
mais est-ce qu'on est encore bien venu
écouter on à 65000 personnes sur une les
attentats va avoir pour venir ici pour
être reçus immigrants il y a
je me promène partout dans le monde j'ai
été j'ai fait civile en europe à
l'automne
j'étais à new york il ya quelques
semaines la perception du québec est
exceptionnel ça fait deux ans deux
années consécutives que nous
surperformons le canada l'économie de
montréal et dynamique
nous avons besoin de réformer nos
programmes d'immigration c'est pour ça
que la baisse est temporaire et c'est ce
qu'on fait merci monsieur girard pour
cet entretien
merci beaucoup